so what does it really take to go
full-time
on youtube you know over the last couple
years i've had the privilege of
interviewing over
200 full-time youtube creators
through our channel called video
influencers my friend benji and i
put some of their information in the
tips and things we learned in a book
called youtube secrets
but i really discovered out of that
process of diving deep as well as
building youtube channels myself
six unmistakable traits of full-time
youtube creators so if you want to get
more
views if you want to write your own
checks make youtube your career or your
job
then you're going to love this video and
buckle your seat belt because
some new data has come out about the
creator economy
and right now there's actually 50
million content creators
and 13 million of them are on
youtube this describes that over
a million of them are earning six
figures plus
so based on the math right now the
creator economy on youtube
thousands of creators are earning seven
figures a year over a million youtube
creators are earning
six figures per year and millions more
are earning anywhere between
dollars and a hundred thousand and so if
you're ready to learn what it takes to
start building your
youtube empire smash the like button and
we are going to
dive into this video you know
signal fire revealed that being a
creator is the fastest growing small
business type how crazy is that
that this idea of making youtube your
job or other platforms like tick tock or
instagram
is more practical than ever before and
even though your mom your friend
you know sarah from high school like
doesn't even understand what you're
doing or what you're pursuing
this is becoming more and more practical
especially when you have the right
strategies this has become the fastest
growing small
business type so i've got a question
that we need to ask when it comes to
full-time though
is what does full-time mean for you like
how much money do you need to
earn from youtube i find that when
talking about this topic of
what does it really take to go full time
if you don't define full time
then it's going to kind of be hard to
decide what it takes
so reverse engineer from a target like
what is your monthly
basic needed expenses that you would
need to
go part-time at your job or quit your
job completely
and think about that if you want to
share it then type that in the comments
as well
and this is the coffee with kennel show
if we're just meeting my name is sean
cannell and we're going to be talking
about the six
unmistakable traits of full-time youtube
creators and i have a huge disclaimer
the topic for today
is not about like the one percent
super superstar unicorn creators for
example david dobrik's monthly adsense
checks
have been as much as 270 000 views for
60 million
views you know across platforms there's
people like charlie demilio on tick tock
she surpassed 100 million followers and
is estimated to be worth 4 million at
age 16.
more power to them but what i'm really
talking about
is what's kind of becoming known as the
creator economy
middle class and this is people that are
really
earning 10 grand 25 000 a year 32 000
a year 50 000 a year doing what they
love working from home
and in this case doing it on youtube i'm
going to be talking about these traits
that are of the kind of practical
everyday creator just like you
that's hustled that's put in the work
and that
i've learned from talking to so many of
them like what did it really take
for you to go full time what went into
you building your
career and again if we're just meeting
my name is sean cannell
and i have built a couple different
youtube channels uh one to over a
million subscribers
a couple to over a hundred thousand but
i'm most proud about
our students we've seen so many get that
silver play button and if you
uh want to learn uh about growing
youtube channels
hit the subscribe button if you haven't
yet and we've seen so many different
students in fact our mission
at think media is to help ten thousand
purpose-serving people
create a full-time living doing what
they love while making a difference in
the world
through online video and a huge question
lately
has been like is it too late to start
youtube though because sometimes
you might feel like it's only the
superstars unicorns
those who started back in 2008 excuse me
uh that
are going full time on youtube but
that's not true at all
and i'm gonna share some data and then
get into these traits number one
this is a letter from the ceo of youtube
that revealed that the
youtube economy is incredibly healthy
and strong despite challenges of 2020
and now that we're in 2021
they revealed that the people joining
the youtube partner program
more than doubled over the year before
more than doubled in
just a year that's super cool right and
then
creators are building the next
generation of media companies and that
here in the us
youtube's creative ecosystem contributed
approximately 16 billion dollars to the
u.s gdp in 2019
supporting an equivalent of 345
000 full-time jobs so what i want to
encourage you with like is it full-time
like
this is happening for a lot of people
i'm not trying to over hype it you might
feel stuck like you're not getting views
or like you're trying to grow i get that
but like massive people are doing this
and if you feel like it's crowded
every day in fact i think about i help
people with their youtube channel and
lately every day i'm discovering like
400 new people that are also helping
people
grow their youtube channels i actually
think that's a great thing it speaks to
how big the world
actually is and how different people
like to follow different styles
different backgrounds different teaching
styles maybe different ethnicities or
ages
there's room for you and the data
supports that you know in the uk
uh in 2019 they saw approximately 1.4
billion
pounds contributed to the british gdp
which was the equivalent of 30 000
full-time jobs
and france saw 15 000 full-time jobs so
the global impact of the creator economy
is massive and here's what this report
is not reporting
it's not reporting other income streams
in fact a little bit later on i'm going
to be sharing some resources
about how small channels are going
full-time so stick around for that
and here's another big data point when
it comes to what it really takes to go
full-time
e-commerce has helped uplift retail in
2020 and it could be the key to merchant
success in 2021 what does that have to
do with youtube
it has to do that because of the
coronavirus pandemic there's been a
massive surge in online shopping
which is likely to remain post-pandemic
speaking of other income streams how are
people going full time
they are reviewing products they're
doing affiliate marketing they're tying
their channel
into online shopping online brands
traditional brands are being disrupted
by dollar shave club online razors
instead of going to the store to get
your razors
people are getting their coffee online
they're getting their
sleep aids online like i just saw my
friend jp sears post about
they're getting their blue light
blocking glasses online they're
subscribing to
like online in fact let me know have you
ever purchased something online tell me
in the comments
see e-commerce is just growing which
means there's another revenue source
so that you can work from home and go
full time when you position yourself
right in the creator and youtube
economy and there's the e-learning
market now this is
people creating online courses this is
people that are teaching something
when i talk to thinkific uh some of the
people at thinkific which is an online
course hosting program
they said that youtube creators are
their most successful
course creators and sellers people
earning a living from packaging what
they know
into an online course and since the year
2000 the market growth rate of
e-learning has been 900 percent
and listen to this every dollar spent on
e-learning companies make back thirty
dollars in productivity which is a side
note
it's a super smart move to invest in
online courses that's a
two thousand nine hundred percent roi to
invest in e-learning to accelerate your
skills
how to do things how to go further
faster like whatever it is
but here's what i'm saying is have you
ever thought about creating a course
the global e-learning market will reach
325 billion by 2025
so over the next four years there's
going to be this massive move
we're talking about youtube adsense
e-commerce affiliate marketing
e-learning creating a digital course or
selling some kind of a digital product
this is a massive industry and my
friends it's just
getting started you're not too late
it is a momentum and the next wave is
here now and so
let's buckle our seatbelts and talk
about these six unmistakable
traits but i have a question for you and
that is what is your goal
on youtube tell me in the comments like
are you trying to go full time
is it a hobby for you maybe do you know
how much you need to
live on per month like what does full
time mean do you have seven dependents
or are you a single person that you know
rents a room and you actually
only need like two grand a month and you
you could be full time let me know
uh what your goal on youtube is and
let's talk about the
six unmistakable traits of full-time
youtube creators
and so number one is they have posted
over 100
videos most youtube creators that have
gone full time have posted over 100
videos
and probably 400 or more does that
intimidate you
smash like for if you've posted your
first video
and let me know if you've posted a
hundred have you posted 400 yet
and where does this data come from well
tubebuddy actually did a study
of 3.5 million of their users and they
revealed
how many subscribers youtube channels
have compared to their uploads
so channels that have reached 1 000 to
10 000 subscribers
have uploaded 152 videos channels that
have
grown up to anywhere between 10 000 to
100 000 subscribers have uploaded
418 videos if you go from 100
000 subscribers to 1 million subscribers
it's over a thousand videos
and channels with 1 million plus subs
are nearing
4 000 video uploads it could be
that you just have not uploaded enough
videos
yet what does this tell me it tells me
that what it really takes to go full
time
is patience persistence
grit tenacity focus
discipline and uploading videos to
youtube you know the secret to success
on youtube
is uploading videos to youtube right
i mean obviously there's more that goes
into it than that but if you're just
like watching this video
and hanging out on the coffee with
kennel show and you're not posting
videos well it's gonna be hard to grow
if you don't actually post videos
let me know how many videos you've
posted yet and huge key
is there's such a range because this
doesn't even indicate if they're
full-time or not
i know some channels that are over 100
000 subscribers that are still
struggling to pay the bills
and i know channels that have gone
full-time at 10 000 subscribers so this
is just
one aspect of really going full time
but trait number one is they have posted
over 100 videos i think there's
something magical about what you've
learned especially if you've got a
strategy
trait number two is they don't rely
on youtube adsense they don't rely
on youtube adsense those that are going
full time and i actually dm'd a couple
friends
that uh are some of our students some
different people that have
you know gone full time i i i dm jen
from the sewing report
and i said um what are your streams of
income she says she has
three monetized youtube channels amazon
affiliates etsy shop
she has a realtor client that she does
video production and social media for
that also gives her her youtube adsense
and so multiple streams of
income my friend ruslan i said hey what
are your streams of income he's been
full time he just built a new studio
adsense patreon musicbed streams he's an
artist hip-hop artist as well as kind of
a commentary in the christianity and
faith space
distrokid which would be apple music
merch shopify
and of course e-learning he's finishing
it now
his second course that he's working on i
asked cass thompson who just dm me one
of our students
and said um she said i'm quitting my job
in january or a couple like couple weeks
ago
of 2021 and she said i've got at least
five
income streams that was able to help her
do that uh simply sherry said last year
the majority of my income came from
brand sponsors and affiliates
uh i didn't hit a couple months of my of
my highest ad sense she had her highest
months of adsense for a couple months
and our goal this year is to build out
e-commerce and courses while maintaining
others
and so so many different pathways
chris from flyride listen to this like
you might you might want to rewind the
video to just write down like man you're
dropping some bombs like
uh okay these are all his income streams
and he's been full time and even scaling
his
business and whatnot youtube adsense
his creator fund brand deals pod merch
physical goods
digital affiliate products physical
affiliate sales amazon patreon and
youtube memberships
digital courses private group
memberships one-on-one coaching and
professional service
and that's it so here's the deal friends
you want to go full time
yes there's some people who do it off
just youtube adsense but you need a
massive audience to do that number two
traits of highly successful full-time
youtube creators
is they don't rely on youtube adsense
number three
they have created multiple streams of
income that echoes what i just
said there and that was some examples of
they have created multiple different
streams of income now
i want to encourage you to not think oh
shoot i'm just starting i have one video
posted
i need to be thinking about my 10
streams of income no you actually
should focus on influence first and
realize that income comes second
and if you spread yourself your focus
too thin too soon
it can actually be harmful but just to
encourage you
that you want to build out the most
synergistic and aligned
income streams related to your niche and
eventually you might have one two three
four
five that are all synergized around your
niche that will help you
get to that full-time mark number four
they work really hard
they work really hard i mean this might
be obvious but i don't know if you
realize
how true this is so over the last
years of building up training our book
youtube secrets my friend benji and i
co-author of the book
we interviewed we had a weekly interview
show we still do he does it called the
vi show on saturdays
we interviewed over 100 youtube creators
before we wrote this and another 100
since then
and one of the common traits i noticed
from every single creator i talked to
back in the day when we could go to
in-person events
and i would sit at vince vidsummit and
talk to somebody or our event growth
video live or
social media marketing world is i would
hear the real hustle that went into
things this takes real work
and i think when we also juxtapose the
middle class
creator this is just your average
everyday creator that turns this
into a really awesome business that
gives you autonomy
that does allow you to work when you
want do what you want
but it's not without the hustle and the
grit and the grind
the top one percent may be because of
their personality or their timing
or how they hit the algorithm kind of
show off a life that may or may not be
true
and they might not work very hard it's
possible but i'm telling you
that a common trait of full-time
youtube creators is that they grind
i'm not saying they have to sacrifice
the things that matter most in life
but without a doubt they have endured
through a sacrifice season
they have put in the hustle they have
put in the grit
in fact let me know if you're doing that
right now they've worked late nights
they've got up early mornings they've
shot videos when they didn't feel like
it
they've cracked red bulls when they
needed that extra push to get a project
done
they have gone through the ups and the
downs of their personal finances and
their relationships
and their marriages and their things and
they have stayed consistent to say i
know that consistency is king
so i'm going to keep posting videos
full-time creators
work really hard you know thomas edison
is famous for saying opportunity is
missed by most people
because it's dressed in overalls and it
looks like work don't ever think being
connected to the think media community
that we propitiate some kind of a
pipe dream of just it's just this easy
opportunity just post a video and you're
going to see a million dollars
transferred to your bank account
bank account no friend this takes a real
grind in a real grit
you can work smarter and not just harder
but without a doubt it takes hard work
when you are really growing and making
this your
full time income and it's a common trait
that i see across
full-time creators number five they keep
learning
i mean i really lifelong leaders are
lifelong learners as
i have been around especially at events
like our event growth video live and i
get around full-time creators
one of the things i notice is they have
a particular type
of personality and that is man they're
listening to audio books
they're reading books and so by the way
not everybody reads books
like they're listening to podcasts
though they just purchased two online
courses
they're studying youtube channels
they're hanging out in the right
clubhouse rooms
like they keep learning they get
connected to
mastermind groups maybe not a paid
mastermind group or maybe it is
but they want to get to around other
people they're getting feedback on
thumbnails what's the algorithm doing
what's the latest things that's
happening just like you obviously if
you're connected here on think media
but they keep learning lifelong
leaders are lifelong learners and these
traits
many of them are also shared behind
those who don't just have
a moment of success but are building a
sustained legacy
so number five is they keep learning
and leveling up so they can't just so
they don't just get ahead
but they can stay ahead number six let
me know if you're getting value
and hit the like button they build
systems for sustained
success they build systems for
sustained success so what do i mean they
build marketing systems
like you've probably noticed that as
you're trying to
build up your youtube channel and
there's really three seasons there's the
side hustle season when you've got a day
job or
school or another responsibility there's
the solopreneur season
where you're full time but it's just you
and there's the scale season where
you're full time but you have other
people helping you and in every season
you need systems
in the side hustle season it's maybe
software that helps you
get video ideas more quickly like a vid
iq or something like that
it could be social media software that
helps you schedule and automate
your posts it could just be
understanding youtube systems of
scheduling and
uploading your videos or scheduling
posts on facebook just with the native
scheduling features that's like a
marketing system
they are building an email list and
using an autoresponder so there's
automation
to their messages going out they're
leveraging systems they're using systems
in their personal day
day planners don't get it twisted this
takes real work
and if you are scattered if you're all
over the place
if you can't personally manage your time
before trying to build a youtube empire
it's going to get very difficult
when you're trying to manage your time
and life and responsibilities and
also build a youtube empire so they use
systems this is also business systems
right business systems
are are like they're using bench dot
which is a book bookkeeping service or i
don't know you use h r block or turbo
tax or whatever you use
but you're they're using systems they're
finding ways to save
time because if you're going to kind of
juggle it all and how do you do it all
you got to work smarter and not just
harder you're putting in the work
but you're not just going pure grit
you're thinking about man
what systems can i use to make this
sustainable and then they're thinking
about teams
and systems so how am i eventually
working with a team
and then eventually building systems for
that team
so as you scale these days we use things
like slack and monday.com
you might want to check out even a
service like sean one of the biggest
things that takes my time
is video editing and that's why we talk
about vid chops and we'll drop a link
to uh our resource page it's called
thinkmediatools.com and i'll put that in
the description down below
and thinkmediatools.com we talk about
different tools
software systems things that will help
you go further
faster but when you get something like a
vid chops
you just dropbox your footage eventually
get a synergy going with your editor
and then they turn around your video and
send it back to you two days later
and now you have a system my friend
tanya eliza one of our students
not only full-time with less than a
hundred thousand subscribers but she has
a multiple seven-figure business
she shoots three videos at a time that's
a system it's called batch producing
she sits down shoots three videos she
puts those three videos
into dropbox she has an editor those
videos are now being processed
they eventually go to her youtube
channel and they're put out
into the world you are maybe pioneering
your systems right now to where i
created
a system it's called video ranking
academy
and we talk about the seven r's uh of
our 7r youtube
system this was how i was able to stay
organized consistently rank videos
consistently grow
but now tony ariola on the think media
team
implements the 7r system if you really
want to go
full time there's something super
powerful
about maximizing and creating systems
for sustained success okay
now we're going to talk about the
seventh trait i know i told you six
traits but this is the seventh trait and
this trait actually
many full-time creators have actually
ignored this one and suffered it maybe
i don't know 50 50 maybe half the
creators i've interacted with
many are missing the seventh trait but i
believe this is a
key trait that you absolutely want
for sustained success on youtube um and
some have it
some don't we'll talk about that in a
second but smash like if you've been
getting value
and today's coffee with kennel is
actually brought to you by full-time
influencer
i'm excited because on this theme of
going full time i did just release this
is actually only available for a few
more days
um and i talk about how i got fired and
started a new business with youtube and
replaced my income if you're curious
about my story and the exact
business model because i was able to go
full time
at 16 000 subscribers with think media
so not a huge audience
and if you're curious about monetization
um
different ways of building your income
with a small audience and it's just my
story step by step
check that out free class full-time
influencer new class and actually coming
down soon so definitely
rsvp uh the replay is available uh
to watch instantly but that's coming
down soon but let's talk about this
seventh trait
i don't know if you've noticed but a
while ago there was a whole bunch of
articles
about burnout are youtube's algorithms
fueling creator
burnout uh cnn youtube burnout is real
creators are struggling to cope uh study
breaks why are so many creators
suffering from burnout
when it comes to burnout youtube is
failing its creators and then even on
medium
instagram youtube tick tock are burning
out
their creators it's not funny but i
actually saw a clubhouse room
which is a new social media app audio
app that already had a title
how to avoid clubhouse burnout clubhouse
is only two months old and people are
burning out already which is not
surprising because that is a whole
nother story
of how intense that app can be but the
reason i bring that up
is it really brings up the importance of
the seventh trait
which is highly effective full-time
youtube creators
sharpen the saw they sharpen the saw
what does that mean well steven covey in
his book the seven
habits of highly effective people which
i highly recommend
the seventh habit is sharpening the saw
what does that mean it means
they seek continuous improvement and
renewal
professionally and personally so highly
effective youtube creators
seek continuous improvement that's not
just learning but also renewal
rest getting refreshed sharpening the
som means
persevering and enhancing the greatest
asset you have which is you
so it means having a balanced program
for self-renewal in the four
areas of life physical social mental and
spiritual
so people that are sharpening the saw
are
eating right exercising resting they're
making
social and meaningful connections with
others they're getting off of social
media sending down their phone getting
off a clubhouse
and talking to somebody face to face i'm
not trying to hate on clubhouse it's
intense over there
uh they're learning they're reading
their writing they're teaching they're
spending time in nature
they're praying they're meditating
they're listening to music they're doing
art they're doing acts of service and
they're helping others
the reason i bring this up not to get
somber for a moment
but this is serious is now being in this
thing for over 10 years
interviewing people that were in this
you know are in this book
i've seen people come and go i've seen
people blow up their marriages
seen people get crazy not know how to
handle fame
i've seen people get money and lose it
i've seen
i've seen youtube creators here one day
and gone tomorrow
they haven't been able to handle
sometimes the success
or the pressure or they went so hard
and were so driven so this is not to be
confused with the fact that i believe we
need to work hard
and be ambitious and have drive to break
through in the industry
but my friends this is so important to
me and why i think this is the most
important trait
you need renewal professionally and
personally
you've got to pace yourself youtube is a
marathon and not a sprint
you've got to have a long-term vision to
realize yes there is time for
short-term sprints but any athlete knows
that you can't continuously grind you
need a recovery day
and that your recovery day or days are
just
as critical as your days when you're
grinding and hustling so
if you really want to go full time not
even just reach that mark
but actually sustain this over the long
haul you got to make sure you're
sharpening the saw
so and i want to encourage you don't get
so wound up in anxiety
or drive or pushing to where
you're sacrificing massive amounts of
sleep
you're sacrificing friendships you
really don't
want to get to the top and be all alone
have you ever heard somebody say
it's lonely at the top you know if it's
lonely at the top it means you did it
wrong
because you can
experience massive success while at the
same time not losing your soul
in fact our mission statement like the
asterix is
helping 10 000 purpose-driven people
create a full-time living while making a
difference in the world with youtube and
online video and experience that success
without losing their soul
and that's not possible if you don't
sharpen the saw you know what good is it
to climb to the top of the mountain only
to realize that you climbed the wrong
mountain
which would be reaching some kind of
youtube stardom
but hitting a wall of burnout and
there's no shame for those that have
burnt out or that get tired or get
fatigued but i do think that it's
possible to build a life
in a business and be intentional and
smart that we don't have to go that way
that doesn't have to be the model we
don't have to grind
you know eight days a week 26 hours a
day
there's some things that are not
possible and there's something powerful
about pacing yourself because youtube is
a marathon
and not a sprint smash like if you
are pumped about sharpening the saw and
let me know when's the next day you're
taking off when's the next day you're
taking some me time
and uh getting refreshed and think about
how you can
get refreshed physically social you know
entrepreneurship itself which is really
being full-time on youtube is also an
energy game
like this takes energy so you know you
didn't come to this video for like
being me bringing up eating or
exercising or resting
but those are critical components i
believe they're diametrically connected
to going full time on youtube key over
the long haul
not like reaching some level of success
and your health's all blown out and your
adrenal
glands are fried because you just
constantly burnt on stress and caffeine
like there's something about building
with wisdom
and creating sustainable success hey if
you're interested in more content like
this and want to check out our free
uh class that's available for a few more
days specifically on how to become
a full-time content creator
fulltimeinfluencer.com link in the
description down below today's episode
of coffee with kennel
is brought to you by
fulltimeinfluencer.com and i want to
pass the question off to you
again what is your goal on youtube
and would you say you have been
sharpening the saw and
you're running a good pace have you been
running
too hard and maybe you feel a little
burnt out other than a little
drained or are you actually maybe
not even really hustling like or have
you noticed that maybe you're just kind
of
dwelling and just hanging out online and
kind of watching stuff but you're not
putting in the grit in the grind
we all find ourselves a different place
on the journey so i'd love to hear from
you in the comment section
below and if you are here live
welcome back coffee with kennel show
smash like fired up to be here live
we're gonna bring some guests on
and answer some q a in just a second um
and uh would love to see
uh how you're doing pumped to uh
see you evolving with etta not on the
grind
maybe time to get on the grind uh let's
see we got crystal i
am a youtuber just trying to grow my
business my youtube channel i want to
let you know that i'm
um selling spider patients is the key
cool uh let's see we got sausage a i
feel more burnt out trying to find my
niche in making a youtube banner
hey nolan mull on think media made an
awesome video
about um youtube banners and channel art
so definitely check that out that could
have you go
quick the niche thing is kind of a
bigger piece and a bigger picture
um check out full-time influencer if you
haven't yet and i got tony ariola today
helping me
and if you want some details on that
that is
right there on screen
fulltimeinfluencer.com
i love it we got joshua in the house
taking baby steps build each week in
each month yep brick by brick
little by little a little becomes a lot
and we got
shade tv sharpening the saw is key
refresh crime is very important as a
former college
athlete i can attest i love that
and thanks so much for sharing we're
going to be taking your questions
throughout
this uh uh coffee with kennel today but
we've got
if with ryan coming up for our first
guest
uh ryan how's it going really well
it's going really well i appreciate you
having me on absolutely where where are
you from ryan
uh so i'm from florida um the channel is
uh intermittent fasting with ryan
um so looking to go full time can't wait
to be one of the uh
one of the 10 000 you all have helped so
been in vra since november
yeah so awesome well how can i help
today
hey so my question is um you know i feel
like i'm at a point to where
i want to move into the side hustle
season i've got a little bit of
affiliate going on i had a startup
company reach out to me
to promote some of their products i got
my first you know affiliate check for
six bucks
uh just a little over 212 i think with
inflation i'm probably right there with
you
yes i binge a lot of the think uh
the think material if you can't tell um
but my question is what is the best way
for me to
reach out to some companies to possibly
do some sponsored videos so if i'm
looking in my niche
there are certain brands that do
um sponsorships of videos throughout so
what's the best way for me to reach out
to them uh
like just off the top of my head thrive
market is one that comes to mind
i know they already sponsor youtube
videos so what's a good way for me to
reach out and say
hey you know i've got 1600 subs whatev
what's a good way to start that
conversation for companies that i
already know are doing sponsorships yeah
that's a great question what i would do
to reach out to companies
of course this takes an investment so
you have to consider that but what i
would do
is um sign up for something like
thrive market as an affiliate um order a
couple things or jump on one of their
sales or whatever
and actually make a video um you know
without them being a sponsor i would
then make that video
kind of smart like um and
let's see here we'll go five uh thrive
market
and let's actually find like a video
idea so maybe even before i do my order
maybe i do a coupon codes video i mean
that's interesting i don't know if they
expire but that's
that might rank uh and then maybe i do
a favorites or um you know you're
definitely doing keto and i know there's
competition on this so i'm looking for
something
that's like kind of niche so i might do
a keto starter kit
let's say and so i might i may niche
down to something like this
and this is kind of a good example
because all right you got some big
channels that you are battling with
but this top-ranked video here is two
years old um
this video is actually on thrive market
itself just for example
and and then i would invest um
you know some real intentionality in
making a video great i'd just be
thoughtful about
kind of hooking attention and and and
essentially trying to get that video to
pop off
around a search term and not just in
search but unsuggested you know as you
would know and being in vra
and so then the goal would be to see
that video
start to perform then you kind of need
time but to see that video
you know kind of like your 2 200 viewed
video
i would want results like that to send
brands
so then you've got uh that video to send
to thrive to say hey
and maybe at the next level it's just
like i'd love to collab
you know is there any way you ever you
do brand deals or even give like credits
so that i could review more stuff
and even opening up a pipeline of free
things from them which then
helps you move forward helps you build
momentum on the affiliate snowball
and other ways to cultivate that after
you've put that video out
kind of essentially built like a
portfolio item
you know as a an example when i was
getting freelance work i wanted to work
for a particular
author speaker i made him a promo video
like
i actually took his b-roll got a
voice-over
got some music and made it made a promo
video and sent it to him
so it's kind of like that exact idea
like wasn't paid for it he'd even know
it was coming
and it opens up that conversation and
and
then got a hold of him started talking
to his assistant the whole deal
it was tipped off by kind of building an
asset for your portfolio
um that you can show to brands that
you'd like to work with once you've got
that video doing well
um you could also send that exact same
video to
other brands so you go here's an example
of something i did for thrive market
even if it wasn't a brand deal that is
accurate it is something you did
for or related to thrive market so again
you're able to show them and you're able
to show them that the video has two
thousand three thousand four thousand
five thousand views
and um that's that's kind of the
approach i would take and i would let
that snowball and the cool thing about
that is
especially because you're connected to
our content you know my thesis that
products are influencers
so sometimes it actually could be that
you also
drill down on thrive market and maybe
find something that's trending
and you try to jump on something that is
uh really trending in regards to
say supplements let's see if we could
say top rate most popular
so most popular is sort of like a way of
yeah you know just like we would do
keyword research
just determining maybe some and maybe
some of the most most popular 30
youtubers are covering it
so what is kind of right like maybe
that's not like a list popularity but
it's right in that b
list popularity and each one
of these types of products is an
influencer potentially
so you know what i mean is zinc
supplements is a way people could find
you
dr berg for hair for
acne and and you want to stay on brand
so you're going to stay in i believe
keto right or at least intermittent
fasting yeah so you get it but like
you could drill down inside of here and
then those would be the types of things
i would put an order into it but you
know by the way i
i picked up you know this raw code uh
you know raw perennial
uh prenatal i should say which is
probably not gonna be a product you're
using or recommending
but i picked up these pre-natal prenatal
vitamins from um
you know thrive market link in the
description down below but if you get
these hemp infused
recovery gummings for example you know
that
ends up being um you know 10 thrive cash
and you kind of growth hack that
and that one product could trigger you
know some momentum
that gets you awareness brings an
affiliate income
immediately but then leads to the open
doors of conversation what do you think
ryan
no i like that a lot i think i think
that's really good showing providing the
value up front
um and then another quick question uh
so i'm doing i took the advice of
starting a show and the show that i'm
doing is what i eat in a week so i've
lost about 60 pounds over the last 10
months people always say
what are you eating so i thought show
idea so for the last probably 13 14
weeks i show
everything that i've eaten in the week
in my keyword research
thanks to vra i realized that's a highly
searched
keyword with medium to low competition
so i do what i eat in a week my question
is what's the best way to title those
because every week i'm doing what i eat
in a week that's the key word i want to
rank for
because those videos are getting tens to
hundreds of thousands of views
within a week of upload so i'm i'm low
on competition but
how do i title coming out with a show
every week what i eat in a week so that
i can rank
in that search well first of all if this
is what you eat in a week and you lost
60 pounds like i need to watch this
video
it's amazing it is like um it's
intermittent fasting you gotta head over
to internet
yeah come on and uh go subscribe to
intermittent fasting with ryan and ditch
those yo-yo diets and
eat good and and eat those pork rinds
and drop that weight
so um that's epic you know i think
what's happening too
is you're you're you're doing it right
because you're building
um uh so much momentum this is i would
say what your subscribers want to see
yes so to have this many views in 1900
like
you're you're building a movement you're
building this with your subscribers
and it's kind of less about search as
you can see here but nevertheless these
are getting the views because it's
suggested recommended browse features
so i would say you're doing it right and
i would just keep getting creative
with how you type this out and say it
for example
you may go to co-schedule headline
analyzer
and and just you know start thinking
about
uh how you could get really well-written
headlines
uh to okay you gotta enter this i'm not
gonna enter right now but
what you can do is let me see if i could
refresh it
it's not gonna let me without entering a
password
whatever okay so rate your co-schedule
headline analyzer which i've recommended
before and once you're inside of there
and logged in it's free
um and it'll and just make sure that you
just try different combinations of
honestly the same thing
but potentially you know making the
words pop off with
how you're optimizing that title does
that make sense it does
yeah cool awesome ryan well hey congrats
on all the success
and uh great job on um your growth and
your momentum keep it up because this
you're on some serious momentum here and
i'm excited to see the rise and excited
to hear the results about how it goes
with some of the affiliate marketing and
eventually brand deals with companies
like thrive market
appreciate it thank you all right take
care
coffee with cannell smash like if you're
getting value
co schedule headline analyzer is a
really cool
resource if you've never used it and all
you got to do
is log in there's also a headline extent
there's also a a browser extension that
you can install
but let me actually think about
if i can log in here maybe this is all i
had to do
yes yes
yes and we could do what i eat in a week
now that i didn't feel the pressure and
stress
and we're in a pro trial right now here
we go
and watch this so there's a there's a
pro version
this is a trial of the pro version but
uh
ryan's current title what i eat in a
week 80 pounds a year
gets a 64. your goal is to get to
70 and it's saying increase
your power words it's saying
increase your emotional words and there
is tools over here on the right side and
it
bottom line is you want to get your
headline score
to a 70 uh or above
and so we will oftentimes think about
how can we make our titles not just
keyword research
um on uh youtube
but also how can they be very
readable and so if you take a title like
this i don't know how well this one will
score
but we'll see so you throw it in there
and
this got a 71 so the goal is to go for
green
and it could still be better how to
research youtube video ideas that
get views and you know sometimes you
maybe could hack this
how to research uh
powerful let's put a power word in there
powerful and see if that
it length matters so sometimes if
oh i put a power where i actually put a
power
full word in there and and that's the
kind of stuff that maybe pops off the
page though because it's like how to
research
good or uh unique i don't know if that's
that's a maybe a different emotional or
uncommon word and let's see how that
does yeah it actually dropped it to 68
and kind of like luke skywalker
sometimes you need to
pull the goggles off when you're flying
in the trench on the way to blow up the
death star and just use the force
sometimes you know the title is good but
use tools like that to analyze your
titles
analyze your headlines and they can
actually help your
especially with what ryan's doing make
your titles maybe pop
so that your subscribers click on the
video that's where most of the traffic
is coming from
with those videos and so definitely
check uh
tools out like that and let me know if
you use any tools or headline analyzers
next up
we've got crystal brown crystal where
are you from what's your youtube channel
and uh how can i help today so i'm from
alberta canada
and my youtube channel is carrero
solutions
awesome did you drop that in private
chat um
i did i can put it back up there again i
did it i got it i got it i got it
um okay how can i help today what's
going on so what we're trying to figure
out right now is there's a lot of
competition i mean we're up against
things like
ted talks and that so my mom and i are
doing this channel and we want to know
are we niche down far enough because it
seems like we just can't
get traction we have almost 40 videos
and
they're getting maximum 20 views spell
out carrero for me
k-o-r-e-r-o
all right okay got it got it
and so the exact question is like how do
i how do you stand out
ted talks is like your competitor well
they're in the same thing we do
leadership training so we're both we're
both mediators and
saw some issues there so want to get in
front of the issues before they wind up
in
harassment complaints basically
very good okay great and let's see a
couple things so
you know first thought is great job of
being consistent and starting out 40
videos so far
um second thought we also have some
youtube shorts here is that what these
are you got the shorts
and yeah those could be interesting over
time because they might hit the short
self
you got it like this one did a little
bit better interesting
best leadership book very interesting
um i would have shown the book
do you ever hold you don't hold it up at
all
uh no no because it's not one specific
book that we talk about
oh gotcha yeah okay so it's like a tip
on it
um just uh okay cool so that's actually
kind of a good example
of just how shorts disproportionately
got more views than your other videos at
76 and then one before and after so that
one
have you looked to the traffic it would
seem that maybe that got picked up on
the short shelf in some level
it did and then it just died right after
okay
so success leaves clues um i was
actually gonna
dial in on the fact that um the
biggest concept i would start with
crystal is
people don't know you but what do they
know so people don't know ryan but they
know
that they want four sigmatic mushroom
coffee which i just ordered by the way
ryan um
and they had their winter sale and so i
just i'm about to
drink mushrooms not hallucinogenic
but healthy mushrooms from for somatic
um but i digress
so people are like looking for reviews
of products they're looking for reviews
of things
products are influencers so we're
authors so if you tie
into best leadership books 2021
or even a review of a leadership book
huge key because again they know the
book they know the product
they know the coffee elixir and if you
could do a search term around that
are you a big reader and do you
recommend a lot of books oh my goodness
i read i have five books
right now i'm trying to get through
what's like a good leadership book that
you recommend
uh start with why okay so that one's a
little bit older but
it's still one of the best ones like if
someone's gonna start with something i
think that's a good foundational
book so um success leaves clues but as
we look at this
you've definitely maybe seen videos like
this this is also
being willing to maybe do a different
content format obviously you're probably
not going to draw and create these
but there are different ways to create
like whiteboard type videos like this
and let's just consider the fact that it
has almost a million views
so you think about what would that be
worth to you to potentially create
book summaries um and this is an
animated book summary
and um that's just one example to maybe
jump on uh the infinite game
because it's newer and less people have
done it and i'm about to crack that one
from
simon sinek so that's kind of the first
thing is
is thinking about youtube is
understanding human behavior and trends
especially when it comes to getting
discovered
so trends meaning even within your niche
it could be um trends
simon sinek start with why a book a
trending book
but it also could be like a trending
methodology a lot of times
things in leadership that maybe are
controversial
new maybe something that you teach
that's controversial and new
not asking you to be controversial for
controversial sake
but you guys could be one video away
from really getting a lot of awareness
because
um there's some sort of conflict
uh management trend that's happening
that is causing division among how
people lead their companies
and the wisdom and insight you speak
into that
it attracts a lot of awareness to one
video
that some people subscribe and they
start following your content does that
spark any ideas
yeah i mean we're working on a top 10
one tomorrow we're shooting and we're
doing um
i'm editing an elon musk and my mom did
a richard branson video that we're going
to try to release
you're going to put the thumbnail right
yes
good you definitely want to figure out
the rules about that if i have to be in
the thumbnail or if it's just a picture
of them in the thumbnail the rules are
very
well i am not a lawyer and this is not
legal advice
but if you're talking about them just
like the news would put
them in uh the thumbnails you know a
conservative
um news commentator that is a part of
our video ranking academy named by bobby
eberly
is um you could see you know mark cuban
mitch mcconnell you know joe biden
and you can definitely see the power of
a lot of his videos that
pop off uh aoc and and
but how does he do this well it's
because
it is you have to view yourself like a
news channel you're in fair use law
you're no different than cnn
cnbc fox news or msnbc
they they like legally
have the same rights as you to create
content that's the power of youtube is
it sort of remove the gatekeepers to
allow anybody
like bobby everly to create their own
media company
so tapping into trending events
thumbnails that could be uh you know
people don't recognize you because they
haven't met you yet but they do know
elon musk naturally so i think you're
absolutely on the right track there
and i do think again there are certain
times like for example
uh on youtube there are sometimes like
like shorts is a great example so like
shorts
is a new uh youtube feature
um it hasn't fully rolled out here yet
it's kind of just testing i'm glad
you've jumped on it
and uh it's it's being really tested
heavily in
india and so it is irresponsible that
actually i don't have a video on shorts
yet but i don't want to talk about
anything we haven't fully tested yet i'm
shooting some next week and we're going
to start rolling out some tests and
we're
been talking to a lot of friends and may
interview somebody who's an expert on
shorts
like legal eagle or ben my friend
authentech has tested a few and
uh kristen from uh six sisters and
different different people all that to
say
is when something comes into your
leadership world conflict management
um philosophy that that is the zeitgeist
that's kind of what everyone's talking
or a new approach or a new
you know people have different of course
frameworks and leadership things that
they use
jumping on that and and you bringing
your point of view to that
could be the key to getting discovered
awesome thank you
that helpful yes awesome crystal well
hey i appreciate you thanks so much for
coming on coffee with kennel
thanks bye sean hey smash like if you
are getting value today on the coffee
with cannell
show um and uh
if you've got a question throw four
question marks before and
after the question
um if you're getting value today maybe
let somebody know
about this show
and we do this every other week and i
encourage you to subscribe
to the channel on think marketing as
well for heather's show called think
marketing
live um and think media has not made a
video on
how to optimize shorts yet but um my
friend alex who i met on clubhouse
you want to put hashtag shorts in the
title and or the description
um under 60 seconds vertical and
honestly uh my friend from snow dogs
uh jess does um
optimize is just like a normal video
because it's still living on youtube so
tags it the same puts a good title puts
a good description
but for it getting onto the short shelf
it is
up to debate how influential that is and
like
authentic ben uh
also puts like a nice thumbnail on it
and
that's not for the short shelf uh this
is a rabbit trail for those who maybe
don't know it shorts but he puts like a
full screen so you can see that this is
a short
but he puts a full screen thumbnail up
so you can see
seven tiny hidden spy cameras it's a
nice
clean thumbnail but then the video
itself is a short
under 60 seconds vertical and um
and it's definitely a new feature that
you may want to consider that we're not
going to talk about today
but that we will talk about
more in the future especially after we
um test them on think media
and elsewhere uh johan says how much
should i charge for my first
course depends on the length of the
course depends on the niche depends on
the content probably the best resource
is fulltimeinfluencer.com link in the
description down below
on that web class i talk about creating
my first online course
which was actually not even my first
online course but all that to say
i talk about the good the bad the ugly
the failures the mistakes and what i
learned
so just go to fulltimeinfluencer.com if
you have if you thought about packaging
what you know into an online course then
you're going to love that free
web class that is out now and we have
lara up next am i saying your name right
you are it's laura
laura uh where are you from and what is
your youtube channel and how can i help
i'm from california
awesome yes love it so
my channel is about essential oils
brand new channel i was like okay
sean you are like the go-to man when it
comes to youtube
so what kind of video
to get in the top rank okay and what is
your channel called
or is it not even any videos yet i don't
think there's
any videos yet okay gotcha so
uh thanks so much for coming on coffee
with kennel you know to
to get in top rank um is
there's let's define what that would
mean you either want
someone to type in a search term and
find your video or you want your video
to start um being shared
and being suggested and recommended by
youtube i think what would be really
interesting right now
would be um i i know i said i wasn't
going to talk about shorts
based on everything i've been studying i
might go all in on youtube shorts
if you're starting a new channel and
here's what i mean if we go
essential oils hashtag shorts let's see
if there are any
um and
we make some videos let's see
this has no sound which is not good
right um and if we
solved problems like so this is top
essential oils for woodrow
this is not a bad actually um
concept to start but voice over
and or music and or um
like so watch this creative uses
for essential oils so you could
brainstorm
and prove trending videos
like this this one hey guys welcome back
to my channel so you can prove that it's
doing
well and it's got and it's like hacks
but you could actually do
five or three creative uses for
essential oils
and put those on for example youtube
shorts
and they also could be from a
perspective
of um you could see like these are from
a perspective of like hands and whatnot
that that would be uh
one thought because those could get onto
the short self and no one's using
youtube shorts
so it'd be interesting to have 5 10 15
20 shorts those could bring some
awareness bring some subscribers
insane things are happening with youtube
shorts depending on the niche
um one of the people that i uh
have been talking with is getting 250
million
views a day just on a niche youtube
shorts
channel um and then i guess a huge key
is there's a million other questions but
it leads to awareness at least
to subscribers and then you can take the
conversation elsewhere but the last
thing i would say is success leaves
clues i think that
thinking yourself is
you just make make videos and make all
kinds of videos make top 10
ways to use essential oils um i think
you could use a tool like vidiq
and so i'm going to turn on the in
inline keyword
thing here and how to use essential oils
at home i'm clicking the keyword
and then i'm going to look over here and
and let these videos inspire you on the
right side these are trending videos
cotton ball hacks i don't know that that
could be relevant
and and just 18 must try essential oils
hacks
interesting and maybe turning some of
those into five different
shorts videos like youtube shorts but a
couple different videos that's
interesting
um but following
what's gotten views before this i i just
talked about that the other day on think
media and someone was like well
i want to actually just be original and
i would rather than try to compete with
the big channels
i just kind of want to talk about what i
want to talk about and make what i want
to make which is fine but
success leaves clues and so i'm not
saying
copy the videos but i'm saying get
inspired by
i'm sure you have your own essential
oils hacks you have your own
insights but nevertheless videos that
are proven because they have twenty
thousand fifty thousand two hundred
thousand views
what that is revealed is that people
want to see topics like that so if you
ever say
what topic should i be creating
study out what's getting results and
then imitate it
in your own unique way okay
is that helpful any follow-up questions
totally
i just left my brain
so i'm sure i'll have more i'll have to
get to you next week
awesome well thank you so much for
coming on coffee with kendall i
appreciate you
thank you
yes friends hey coffee with kennel the
average attention span for videos
is two minutes not necessarily true uh
perry but for some that could be true
i think across youtube on average it's a
four minute kind of is the middle of the
road
when it comes to attention span but uh
one of the goals that you want to do
with your content
is average percentage viewed so for
example youtube short can only be one
minute
but an average percentage viewed could
be 100 if they watched
all 58 seconds of your 58 seconds short
but what i would encourage you uh perry
and everyone
is you can actually see depending on the
length of the video
um how much your video compares
to the rest of youtube so let's check it
out
um this video is very short and we can
click see more here in analytics
and there's not just audience retention
so this video is three minutes and 27
seconds
but there's relative audience retention
and you can see that this is
outperforming
youtube's average until the moment when
i let people know
i'm landing the plane and then it jumps
below average
maybe i should have ended the video
quicker now
let's check like a really long video
that video is only three minutes
let's check out my video on clubhouse if
you have questions about clubhouse maybe
check it out
and this particular video we have the
audience retention
and we could say the relative audience
retention is pretty good here
it's pretty below average for the rest
of the video and notice it actually
comes back to average at 10 minutes
because for whatever like it doesn't
really hold
the average audience very good here but
the people that make it here are so die
hard like
you know you can see that so i don't
know if you've ever studied your
analytics like that before
but then what you can also see is you
can see your uh your channel average
in general and so you could say your
average view duration on your whole
channel is four minutes and 53 seconds
and i think that compares pretty close
right around four minutes is the average
on
youtube and it's super to to you
your point perry it depends on the niche
depends on
uh so many different factors and um
things to be looking at though what's
the average of your channel how can you
increase
particular videos ralph sean's the man
thanks for the super chat
his advice helped me grow and get
monetized you're one video away from
blowing up fact i'd appreciate a channel
review thanks
shawn well
in honor of the super chat we are going
to do a quick
channel review please no more super
chats for channel reviews more super
chats please but
not in exchange for channel reviews uh
because how to grind gotta hustle gotta
do some things
but let's do a quick channel review um
all right so we got uh ralph's
channel uh definitely see the cars
that's clear
and so uh documenting my journey of
creating content along the way
cool looking to spread some value
through youtube to everyone
i would you know not a lot of people are
going to go to your description but i
would i would work on this
because i would define what the value is
and i would define yes documenting your
journey so i may or may not want to
watch that
and you're certainly having some
momentum and success but like
what is the value um am i going to learn
something
entertain am i going to laugh and and
you may be approaching your content
thinking about that it just doesn't say
that there
okay so as i come over here okay a lot
of
uh okay so
wasn't really expecting this definitely
see that
with like the cars that that's connected
to potentially wealth
but a lot of things about stocks and
bitcoins and things like that bitcoin
it looks like things are going well and
so i could see
something up here not that your cover
image is everything but i actually could
see
something like i could see your profile
image
maybe changing a little bit because yeah
there is the car flex
but it's also like i don't know what's
going on i can't really recognize you or
the car
and maybe if you shot the photo in a
different place so there wasn't like a
busy house and like
road behind it but i really do think an
avatar should pop more and be a little
clearer
like it could be your face but what it
also could be is like a little bit coin
or something
um or maybe kind of like a generic coin
uh but
obviously bitcoin is the most
influential so be something imagine if
it was like
your face you know if we just go bitcoin
really quick and look at like a
thumbnail example i think you understand
but
i'm sure there's somebody that maybe
throws a coin next to like a clear
uh you know like kind of like that idea
but maybe a
a gold coin in like your face and it's
slightly behind you or something
just a thought and then it sort of lets
me know because
i went in sort of a weird order but i
don't really know what your channel was
about at first i actually thought it was
gonna be about cars
then i didn't know what the about page
was and then i got to the videos
which are clear and i actually quick and
quickly pick that up when i see the
thumbnails
um i think that uh with the results
you're getting
sometimes though despite everything i've
just said i mean
bro like you're crushing you know
i think uh like even without advice you
know
you just grew by 3570 percent in the
last month congrats
and 2 490 you know i bet you wish your
crypto
currency uh just went up that much right
come on
uh and so that's like massive you're
doing something right and keep
celebrating that
and and keep doubling down which to me
seems to be reacting to markets
going live hustling uh so you're so
what i might think about is maybe a
couple questions as we land the plane
you're moving fast right now which is
great you're taking action
um and it's a lot of stuff's working so
what do i know
but here's what i would ask a couple
questions to maybe chart a big vision is
this
or to take to slow down and think about
your bigger vision
what is the bigger vision for your
channel where is it going to end up
here's the question i really want you to
ask what is the bigger brand
that i want to be known for and how can
you
brand your face
your avatar maybe
without watching your videos how can you
brand your your shows
your your live streams um and
just big thoughts because as you're
going
live as you're jumping on trends as
you're getting known
i would just think you would want you to
be recognizable
um as you grow does that make sense
like a lot of people are doing what
you're doing it's working really well
for you
but how do you stand out and as when
someone keeps to see you
keep seeing you and recognizing you and
you're also having a lot of success not
putting your face in the thumbnails most
of the time
it would seem and also using others but
i would think about
as maybe the last tip and also to add
some value to
uh the whole community here um you can
check out my friend pat flynn
and he does the income stream maybe
um also my friend ruslan
and in fact let me let me take this off
and let me talk about
let me show you one really awesome
branding thing and this is just
this isn't dude you just grew by
thousand five hundred percent in your
views like just keep doing what you're
doing
but so that there's more stickiness more
subscribers and more like memorability
think about how you could level up your
brand and say we do have audio on
so i want to show you roof lawn who does
like a lot of commentary on like
spiritual issues and stuff he's also a
hip-hop artist
um and he's got some of the sickest
branding and
i'm encouraging you especially money gap
you're making and whatnot
level up your live stream and uh
think about let's see he's doing
by the way he's actually experiencing
similar types of success he's going live
he's chopping down his lives that's a
tip like he'll go live
for uh sometimes hours but turn him into
25
16 36 headline based videos
um but let's let's uh let's see maybe a
video that's done well
really well and then let's see
all videos okay okay youtube's like
changing things why can't i go to most
popular
um let's just check this out here we go
recently so that's that's what i'm
talking about like did you catch that i
mean that's it like
very quick recently and he's actually
able to do that at the push of a button
so that's a conversation for another day
but he's built up his battle station
check this out too he's built up
multiple angles uh just kind of
pretty wild debauchery he's the guy who
passed out from getting too high and
drunk on uh no
jumper adam's 22 that was like a big
deal and so to see him
boom and he can tap a switcher and
change angles pat flynn is doing some of
the same things
so i i don't think that's the difference
between things
happening what i wanted you to see was
the branding
and pat flynn's doing similar things
like whether that's logo
sound effects audio and and to me
if i have money coming in i'm
reinvesting it in production i'm
reinvesting it
in my setup i'm reinvesting it in
if you will what exactly what you're
doing so that's just the thought
and let's just start this out to get a
vibe on it as well
let's see here
okay so this is a live stream takes a
little while to kick off the start on
that guy
let's check this one what's going on
traders welcome back to another video
recap today we are going to be talking
about the current news update
on amc and gamestop and what you can
expect headed into this week
especially for amc which has earnings on
thursday app
cool cool and it's all working it's all
working i mean i'm again i'm getting
less of like a brand of you
um you got to build your own thing maybe
you don't want to be seen as much but
like
i this is this is intentional you know
like i i want to be recognized think i'm
wearing a think hat
just things like that up to you the
brand you want to build but just trying
to have like artifacts things that are
noticeable branding
um on of course think media people are
like you got to just press record
camera noise like we put that in all the
videos you're doing a lot of live
streams and that's why i would suggest
checking out pat flynn and ruslan
because they go live tap switchers
and tap in little sound effects and
things and that would be the way to
evolve your show and i also noticed
um i level up your gear a little bit too
it's clearly working
but there was kind of some audio maybe
your
room has some echo in it but there was
almost some airy noise and kind of
not the best crispy audio on on your
thing as well
you asked for a channel review that's
some feedback for the channel
that just grew 3500 subscribers and 2
500 new views so uh
you should come on and teach us your
tips
which is probably jumping on hot trends
in personal finance and
the stock market and all that kind of
stuff listen
friends i know we sometimes go marathon
and do coffee with kennel for
hour and a half uh two hours three hours
but there are some things that i have to
accomplish today and i'm gonna be trying
to keep the show more to an hour we are
15 minutes past the hour but listen
if you want to go deeper right now uh
head to uh
fulltimeinfluencer.com if you haven't
watched that class
that's only up until like friday where i
talk kind of about the business model
behind packaging what you know into an
online course
the story of how i went full time some
best practices around that
and even with the small audience how you
could go full time link in the
description down below
fulltimeinfluencer.com
this is the coffee with kennel show i am
sean cannell helping you rise and grind
get your mind right your grind on your
youtube channel growing
and helping you build a bigger business
around your youtube channel every other
week coffee with cannell will come to
you on the think marketing channel
and uh excited for future episodes make
sure you're subscribed if you're not
subscribed i appreciate you
if you're just joining check out the
replay
because we talked about six unmistakable
traits of full-time youtube creators and
the seventh trait
that not every creator has but that's
key to creating a real legacy
in impact as a full-time creator uh
daddy jo
dojo appreciate you life with uh maren
good to see you i appreciate you
evolving with etta you're so welcome i
appreciate you great to have the
philippines in the house
wendy and maxwell and ahmet and oliver
who jumped off thanks for hanging out
and watching
try to get you on on the next one as
well
ruslan is a great friend love him as a
creator love to see his growth
love to see his grind everything traits
of the full-timers man
he has all seven of them uh and uh love
ruslan
you got it ralph uh just got monetized
and made 1k since then
my man great job and uh you're in a high
cpm niche
i hope you're turning on multiple ad
spots because you know some of those
longer videos could have multiple ad
spots
and uh you're giving out good advice
that's definitely a good way to to
get some stuff going and and the small
tweaks lead to giant peaks
and one way to stand out is production
value and
branding um thank you so much for the
super chat pink
creation um and
uh i create my channel to pay for
college can you please help
uh try to try to jump on a future coffee
with kennel because i do have to pick up
speed today thank you john kelly
for the super chat massive love and
appreciation
so grateful for you think crew and
community
listen what do you got to do next what
do you need to do next if you're still
here tell me in the chat
meaning what action do you need to do
next
to move your youtube business forward do
you got a script a video
you gotta shoot a video do you gotta
plan out do some keyword research
do you need to take a nap do you need to
do you need to rest
do you need to get back to your day job
and you're actually
not supposed to be watching this right
now um do you need to level up and learn
a little bit more
do you still trying to figure out your
niche and want to you know
want to watch one of our classes or like
just what do you need to do
mara needs a nap i need a nap i got up
early today
we had the baby spit up like
mount st helens like just complete
volcano eruption
all over the bassinet all over the
dockatot
my wife was saying she goes it was all
over the daca tot i go does anyone know
what a dockatot is
people know what bassinets are do you
know what a bassinet is
all over his little bed thing and then
all over him and so like 2
30 i'm like waking up she's like here
give your baby a bath i'm like what are
we doing it's like 2 30
taking his clothes off like bath water
his spit up is all in his hair changing
him then trying to go back to bed
hey new dad life five month old sean
bradley kennel my
son is a blessing and
a teacher of perseverance and patience
shout out to all the parents in the
house
and uh daca tots yeah charlie
you know you know where it's at that's
right
and um and we got jennifer being honest
you gotta edit we got gil you gotta just
press record that's right that's right
uh keyword research time it's time to do
it
come on yummy kitchen direct all right
hey appreciate your coffee with kennel
keep crushing it keep smashing it and i
will see you in the next episode
peace